[Music]
[Applause]
luno
the fastest easiest way to buy crypto if
you're just getting into bitcoin
it's the perfect place to start hey guys
anna welcome back to
my show it is powered by iconplus as
usual
so a quick news announcement for you so
binazz has just joined icon as a public
representative and made it possible for
its users to stake icx
on binance and earn up to 21.79
interest so that's pretty cool now a
quick shout out to blockbuy they are my
sponsors i use them to add up to 8.6
interest on my usdc you can actually get
um up to that when you sign up so i
think that's pretty cool now before i
bring on my guest because things are
going to get
kind of i'm going to say heated because
she's a pretty interesting guest
um i want to give a quick shout out to
coinflip they also sponsor the show so
you can get 10 off transactions there so
when you buy bitcoin so i'm going to
leave a link for you rolling somewhere
at the bottom
now if you are watching on youtube
please don't forget to hit the like
button and hit subscribe
so you never miss any of these fantastic
guests now joining me today
is uh somebody who's doing some pretty
interesting stuff in the blockchain
industry and
in the crypto space in general it is of
course adrian
ashley how are you doing i am doing
amazing how are you
i'm good it's great to have you it's
great to be it's great to be back on
your show i always enjoy your show
you're just you're phenomenal and i'm
i'm glad that you're actually going
bigger
oh well thank you i appreciate that so
for those that don't know you i really
want you to explain what you do i think
it's best coming from you because
you're a bit of a you're quite fiery and
exotic and exciting so you you tell us
who you are
so i'm a i'm a little bit of a bitcoin
og i got it in 2009
uh didn't really know what i was doing
lost my wallet with 2500 bitcoin in it
kind of got back
in around 2011 2012 and launched lolly
in 2015
so we solved the me too epidemic by
putting consent on the blockchain
and my little pithy quote about what do
you do
uh i have a naughty dating app for good
girls that gets women laid
so that's basically what we do because
women need safety security and certainty
to say yes
the blockchain provides identity
verification it provides
that consent certainty so there's no go
backsies
so it kind of does everything that we
women need in order for us to feel
confident to even go to dinner
okay so that's a lot and i love it and
it's
really cool and it's really different so
i want to go back a second
so you have a dating app called lolly
and it's on the ethereum blockchain is
that right
so yes at the moment it is on the
ethereum blockchain although we are
going to be moving to
e2 because obviously ethan won
my concern i was actually gonna
completely switch blockchains but
uh because i i didn't want to get a hit
with cryptokitties
where a five dollar cup of coffee cost
you 45 in gas
and with our whole reputation and
staking system
the whole point is you know that it's
it's stable it's an
unpumpable token it's not meant to be
ico'ed and then pumped to five bucks and
then drop down to a penny which
you know so a lot of investors are like
oh we can't pump it i'm like
yeah no it's not meant to do that it's
actually a real utility because i don't
want to sell a security because that all
look good in orange
no absolutely not so talk to me about
this app
how does it work so i look i tried to
get it on my iphone but i wasn't sure
that i could
so you can't it's not out and
we actually just had someone release a
dating app called
lolly so we're in negotiations at right
now
and we are probably going to change our
name okay so can you tell take me
through how this is going to look
what can we expect from a from an app
that helps women
date that how that helps put consent on
the blockchain how is this gonna look
so basically you know what normal dating
apps
right they're chock full of bots fake
profiles like eharmony it's all
sign up for free right well yeah you
sign up for free but you can't actually
do anything for free except build your
profile
and then if you want to delete your
profile you can't actually do that you
can cancel
but that doesn't delete your profile to
delete your profile you actually have to
google
to get a very hidden unnavigatable
link to actually delete your content so
there's a lot of people who aren't
actually live on platforms so our
platform is different
in that everyone is actually real and
we're doing that by launching the
consent piece first so it's not a dating
app to begin with
because it's just the consent you gotta
find your own target
but once we get enough
people in each city then we'll roll out
the dating portion of it in each city
so that's how we're going to make sure
that it's actually real people because
most dating apps launch with a test
set of data which doesn't
help you date because they're not really
there
yeah exactly and like too many stories
i've heard about people getting
catfished
um people not showing up and all these
things but when you say
consent on the blockchain i still don't
understand okay
so you know how sometimes you go to
dinner
and the guy thinks because you went to a
steak dinner
that that means he gets sex
you've heard of that yeah of course
often women are afraid to
let a man pay for dinner because she
feels like she owes him something
afterwards
exactly so this way you can consent just
to dinner
if you do through the app through the
app yep you're just like it's it's
what it does is it inspires transparent
communication what are we really doing
here
right uh it's also good for things like
if you're dating somebody in the
workplace and your workplace has
policies that says you can't date
anybody in the workplace
the reason they have those policies is
to eliminate the risk of sexual
harassment claims
right so this way you can use the app
and say yes this is a consensual
relationship but where before we have to
actually go to
human resources and fill out the darn
form and tell them
right but it is consensual and then
when it comes time to actually have
sex you open a consent window
because here's the other thing there are
a lot of uh
very faulty consent applications out
there they don't do anything their
single point of consent
they don't really verify the identity of
the person
and it's not very explicit so ours
actually opens a consent window
um you guys agree it it literally has
like like how naughty can i get we're
not on broadcasting do it no do what you
want
go for it yeah yeah go for it okay well
this will go on youtube and i don't
youtube to
get any strikes against me okay so how
about this
i'm gonna i'm just gonna i'm gonna use
innuendo
do it and if i think if i think you can
go further
then i'll i'll push it further okay uh
you know how there's a percentage of
girls who are
like totally fine with having the back
door
doorbell yeah yeah right well some girls
are
that would probably be good to know for
the guy
before things get started whether or not
that's an option
okay so you would put all of this on the
blockchain and confirm it and make sure
everybody knows what's happening
well no because see everybody isn't
going to know everything because the
whole point is these consents will never
end up on the cover of tmz
it's multi-sig it's not it's not
something that you can just
pull um the only way you can actually
get
the data or heaven forbid something go
wrong
and you use your safe word and it starts
streaming the audio
to our secure servers they're not even
ours they're the community secure
servers
and they're run by lawyers in all 50
states so
you can't get it without a court order
or law enforcement
like it's not for tmz it's not to
both parties know what's happening
everybody if you and i were to go on a
date for example
we'd put an agreement in and then both
parties would know what's happening
exactly and then at the end of the date
or your time together
then you close the consent window and
then
your rating if it if it was a match that
we
set up you would be rating how
compatible you were
how accurate the profile was things like
that so
these ratings are never actually for
public they're only to train the ai
and then when we do the dating piece we
have what's called a heat index and it's
like how compatible
are you and a 5 is basically
fabulous for a one-night stand pretty
compatible both of you are awesome
people
but one of you is just really not
not really good for long term or you
have
some kind of significant core value
mismatch which would make long term
not really viable right so
like you want kids and he never wants
kids that would be a
core value mismatch that doesn't mean
you can't have fun in vegas for a
weekend
but probably not going to get married
and what we found is that most women
really want long-term love
and they set it at an 8.5 and above
on the heat index you're only ever rated
as you would be a couple you're never
rated individually
because that's not what it's about right
we're not making judgment we say there's
a pot for
there's a lid for every pot right so
there is a match out there
and so if you set it for an 8.5 it's
only gonna show you people who would be
long-term compatible
but if you set it down to a five which
our focus group does
probably three to five times a year
usually after midnight
and a lot of times when they're out of
town this is actually how the entire app
was created was at two o'clock in the
morning in a las vegas hotel room when i
was alone horny and had no solution to
my problem
i remember you telling me this yes and
then
yeah go for it oh my big brother uh my
my big brother in social media joel crom
uh basically kicked my butt for six
months and said no you can't
you can't make a hookup app this you you
cannot make a hookup
i was like but dude we need a hookup app
and he's like no you don't women want
love they want marriage they want
both it's not just a hookup app it well
it started off as a hookup app
my button made me do a focus group and
so i did the focus group and
lo and behold as usual
he was right yeah i think so because i i
don't think women like entirely want a
hookup app i think being able to
have both choices is definitely going to
reach a bigger audience
well it would be like what if eharmony
which is you know
that it is literally designed for and
marketed as the marriage app
gave you an option to press a button and
magically uh you know a nice stud muffin
with a six-pack
and talent shows up okay i have a
question on this point though
are actually okay with they want an app
that they're not embarrassed to have on
their phone
that actually has the secret
functionality that every now and again
they can just lower that
and go who's who i have a question
on that exact point okay so i so i
remember we had this conversation i
think it was over a year ago or
something like that
and you were sort of saying you know you
were in vegas or whatever and
you were in a hotel room and you were
alone and you just wanted to have an app
whereby you could just get somebody
delivered to the door basically that
not just like anyone not just anyone but
but somebody who
would assume what you wanted yes
appropriate
but how likely are they to you need to
have the amount of people on the app to
find that right so you need to have
enough users
so how can you guarantee that you're
gonna
actually have have someone for everyone
on an app i believe there's someone for
everyone in the world but how you do you
believe that you're going to get
that exact person because that's what
you guys do right you mark it on being
able to
get that person which is why we're not
starting with the dating app that's why
we're starting with the consent app
because you find your own targets which
we were going to release
last valentine's day and then hello
coven
so basically killed our launch last year
and so now we're we're rebooting
we're rebranding um like i said we have
a little trademark issue
and since they're already out and i'm
not an [ __ ]
uh it's easier for me to change my name
than them to change theirs
we'll see how enough we'll see how it
goes but
so you have an augmented reality feature
yes so talk me through this what does
that mean
so when okay so i go to a lot of
conferences
and at these conferences
you know there'll be 500 people in a in
a ballroom
right at a cocktail party
well i really if i'm interested
in you know fun
then i don't need to meet 500 people
so you can actually hold it up and
anybody else who's on the app it will
show you and it'll give you like the
color-coded heat index so that you can
tell this is a hot target or
a cold target oh wow i see
so oh wow that is insanely futuristic
wait
so you're saying the app knows what you
want as an individual whether it's for a
night or whether it's for a long time
and you're in a room of over hundreds
even thousands maybe of people but that
but wouldn't that assume that they're
already on the app
it would they would have to be on the
app yes right
so this is you tell the app
what you want the more transparent you
are the more honest you are
and this is the big thing with women
when i ask them you know what do you
really want
i've got tissue all over the room
because i know
a good portion of the room is about to
burst into tears
they honestly don't know what they want
and and i think it's funny because
i'm kind of a i'm a badass type a
very control freak very driven very
ambitious
i'm really hard to date like
really hard and then what i what i
always find funny is
i'm actually not that hard if you just
understand that i grew up on smutty
romance novels in disney movies
then you'll know exactly what i want in
a man right i want to be swept off my
feet i want every woman right
but i want to have um i want to have i
want i want
confident competence does that make
sense
competency oh yeah competence is the
most attractive
quality i don't want to drive all the i
don't always want to be the one to drive
i want to be able to take my phone
yes and and no we're still going to get
there and everything's taken care of
it's like when i go on vacation with my
girlfriends right
we're all the same which is hilarious
because people are like
how can that many taipei control freak
women like travel together and like it's
so
easy and just get on everything
is handled somebody somebody literally
steps up so we really only have to take
care of maybe ten percent
of what we generally we're at a hundred
percent so ninety percent of the time
we're like oh god this is so relaxing
right so that's what we look for
in men we want to know that they that
they can handle things without us having
to oversee
it's really interesting because
somebody's just written in the comments
you won't attract an alpha male with
that attitude but i really disagree and
the reason i disagree
is because men i think i think the
person may be watching misunderstood
because you're not saying that you want
to be the alpha in the relationship
you're saying you want to switch off
you want to let him be the alpha i need
someone who can out
alpha me i need someone who
is like i look at that person and i'm
just like
oh my goodness okay my man right like i
want to sink into my feminine which is
almost
impossible with most people like it's
just it's very difficult but like i said
is if if they would just read like 10
smutty romance novels
watch the hallmark channel for a weekend
and maybe like
four or five disney princess movies they
would totally get
what a lot of women need
and yeah i think there's like this
misunderstanding between like ambitious
women because there are some women who
i think are impossible because they
won't let their man be a man or
you know they want to be in control and
i totally understand why that doesn't
work
but there's this misunderstanding that
career women there's i think there's an
idea that career women want to be in
charge in a relationship and
most of us absolutely don't no way you
drive you don't i don't want to honey
i will i i will literally make sure that
you
never leave the house hungry or horny
absolutely that is my duty as your woman
got it i'm good with that i i i
absolutely love to take care of my man
and i do not want to be the alpha in the
relationship
i like that but because of who i am and
how people usually meet me
because i am such an alpha in public and
in business
it's hard to do that transition because
most of the time i don't meet anybody
unless i'm in that environment
yeah i get that i guess you know you can
especially with work that's where a lot
of people end up meeting their other
half
yeah and you're constantly in alpha mode
when you're working so it's harder to
yeah put that that femininity forward
maybe
yeah so okay so your app in order to
work
needs to have all of these people to
pick from like you said this augmented
reality feature it needs to have
all all the guys all the women signed up
so
everybody's in sync and knows what
what's what so
with that in mind how do you then the
great transit you go from
girls parties so everyone has already
signed up for the app that goes to the
singles parties so
oh i say okay right so in a general
conference like a
just a like web summit or some other
conference with 70 000 100
000 people um it's not going to be as
effective but for the singles parties
that we have
on the roadmap that we've set up that
works because
everybody has the app their app is fully
filled out and then when they check in
our people actually validate and give
them like almost like a look score kind
of like
they look at their their application
they look at their their profile and
like how accurate is it
so it's not like it's not like saying
you know this guy's a
you know a nine on a scale of one to ten
it's you know how accurate
is the profile compared to the human
being standing in front of me
yeah you're a nine foot he's a nine for
you basically
but it's not even the nine for me again
remember nobody scored individually it's
really
how accurate is the profile compared to
the human
because the guy oh i missed that song i
could be a six
right look scale in my opinion you know
in in my biased perspective
i could i could consider him a six right
but if his profile is super accurate
that would actually give him a higher
score
oh understood okay so no cat fishing
then basically
that eliminates the catfishing it
eliminates the catfishing and there's a
whole bunch of things that we do that
that uh increase the safety standards
and those are the reasons why we do
things the way that we do even though
people are like that's a pain in the
butt you're gonna have trouble
onboarding i'm like no i'm not
you also have a token though yes because
that's the reputation and staking system
so explain that why are we having a
staking well i understand
i guess because it's a blockchain and
everything needs to be validated and the
consent needs to be validated will go on
well the consent that's that's easy the
consent piece getting validated that's
already i mean
that smart cr contract is already done
that's super super easy
but the reputation and staking
right so a man's worst fear is that
she's going to be fat
in a woman's worst fears she's going to
be murdered how do you yeah
both sides equation right no really and
this is multiple polls over the last
five years
and i'm like i'm not really worried
about being murdered and then i thought
about it i go yeah i don't really go out
so that would be why i'm not worried
about getting murdered
so okay so the
the reputation and staking system is is
critical because
people need to vouch now the other piece
of this that's the sneaky fun part
is your parents can vouch for you your
parents aren't necessarily
single there are people on the app who
are not necessarily single they're
actually there
as as almost like matchmakers as helpers
right they're the friends because the
other fun part is you know your single
friends of friends
some of my best when i drop my
original hinge had it right i would drop
my pin
down in silicon valley and it and i'm
friends with billionaires
and it would be all their single friends
and i'm like
i'm still friends with five of the guys
that i met on hinge back when it
actually worked because i don't think it
works now um
and it was awesome because these were
the friends of
people that i actually know and adore
so of course i'm going to have a a
better affinity with them in the first
place
right yeah no that makes sense
yeah so so the the staking piece of it
is
you know you have people that they'll
they'll show up they'll take one look at
her and they'll leave and they
and they won't even they'll just ghost
right
like that person their stake would be
forfeited
uh they they wouldn't they would they
would lose
their money but they would also lose
their friends money okay so i'm not i'm
not getting the staking part though i'm
not getting the staking part so
to in order to use the apps you have to
stake a certain amount of money
no explain okay
so people can like say you put your
profile picture up right
your friends can go oh that is a that is
a recent picture of her i'm gonna stake
that right
and and they actually earn rewards for
vouching
or statements it's the gamification of
the app with the tokens
where they can use the token they can
use the tokens for in-app purchases
they can also earn tokens by staking
it's almost like
interest but we're doing everything to
avoid any sec
complications so it's it's all
gamification and rewards and loyalty and
things like that
and then what kind of things can you use
to buy with the tokens what features can
you unlock
by background checks you can upgrade to
voyer mode where you can seek but not be
found we have like 50 different things
that you can buy
wow this is uh yeah it's
which is why we're starting with the
consent app because to build the full
app is two and a half million dollars
which we need to fundraise for
to build the consent app less and once
we
launch that then the user id piece we
can also also incorporate into
a lot of other applications that have
nothing to do with dating
but also confirm this is a real human
being
and include the reputation and staking
so it should replace
a lot of the default logins because
it'll just be a simple apk and
the different um websites that use it
will actually earn
rewards themselves it's kind of like you
don't get anything for using the google
login or the facebook login
you know for the social login but say
you're a website owner
and you put this on there you actually
earn
rewards almost like affiliate
commissions every time people sign up
using this because it brings them into
the ecosystem
so okay with all of that in mind then
so i understand that like normal dating
apps i don't i don't use them i don't
like them
i don't want them um personally i just
i don't know i just find this change i
use no i'm not
every quarter oh okay every quarter
on a sunday night usually about 10 30 11
o'clock at night
and then i spend a couple hours swiping
and then uh and then i
ghost the apps again so then i log back
in there like are you here i'm like
dude you got to get me i'm only on the
app for five minutes like you got to get
me like right there
but like these apps i don't really think
they're particularly romantic anyway
right like tinder
is just a hookup app at this point i
don't think it's romantic but my
question to you is
do you think having to lock in these
things and sort of
make that contract on the blockchain of
what you want out of this specific date
sort of number one takes away the
romance and then number two
kind of takes away any potential for any
spontaneity
and so on and so on well if you're just
saying you're consenting for dinner you
can always upgrade it
okay you can upgrade you oh heck yeah
you can one flick no problem
but isn't that but it is isn't that like
really like black mirror
have you seen black mirror do you know
black mirror
yeah i'm laughing because where do you
think they came up with the episode
oh is that from you guys that's the
question
from what i understand it's like friend
of a friend of a friend
i can trace it so pretty have you seen
the episode
yes so it's just oh i don't know
like because they were a lot they they
had an expiration date like they had to
go through
that like hardship together yeah despite
the expiration date
so here's the thing we have
we have an issue with people you know
like this one girl on tinder as an
example specifically
said i'm not here for hookups i'm not
sleeping with you
guy asks her out right covid
says why don't you come to my house for
dinner she goes to his house i'm like
covet or not coven woman you should be
meeting in the park
socially distant six feet apart each of
you on your own picnic blanket what the
heck are you thinking
and she never met this guy before no and
she goes to his house
and he literally mansplained her
why she was supposed to sleep with him
because
those are the rules even though she has
in her thing that she's not having sex
so there's there's so much
well that's very silly of ads i have to
say uh there's so much assumption
right so this makes everything more
clear and yes
there's a way to make it sexy and i i
don't want to go into the entire
marketing campaign of how we're going to
do that but i'll just tell you i have
history
because in in the 80s and 90s
i got people to use condoms which they
didn't want to do but could save their
life
so this is not my first rodeo getting
people to do what they don't necessarily
want to do that's good for them
so i can i i got that part down
it'll be i'm excited yeah i mean i'm
excited to see how you guys do i just
wondered have you had much have you had
much backlash about this
i mean i've been reading the comments
they're pretty interesting because i
think initially
people sort of said that's a very
shallow idea um
but but it's not just a hookup app it's
it's both it's a long term love app as
well
so i just wonder if you've had much
backlash
it uh no not really so i did i just saw
that there uh
that there are yeah we can
let's read them but not my type of women
well here's the thing
not manipulative because the one thing
this is is transparent that's the whole
point
so a lot of women are manipulative
because they're playing
the game this is more of here's exactly
what i'm looking for here's my core
values here's the best part
though when you fill out this and the ai
knows exactly what you're looking for
it is not going to show you somebody
inappropriate so you're not
working through thousands of profiles
especially thousands of fake profiles
like when i first uh got on bumble
where i live trust me i'm in reno
nevada there are not 50 hedge fund
managers and venture capitalists here
they might have at some point in
history on tinder went
skiing in tahoe
but they were definitely not living in
reno
right what the app was telling me matter
of fact i i screenshotted
um my friend's boyfriend i got so mad i
was like
dude what the [ __ ] like i was so pissed
because here's my friend's boyfriend and
they live together and he's on bumble
except he's never i think he's never
been on bumble it was his seven years
prior
tinder profile that was on bumble
that was on bumble oh that's terrible
that's actually really bad that's really
really bad because that can ruin
relationships if
you know it's already quite a rocky one
like i i
i'm in my 20s but when i was maybe like
18 i used to go on
some of the dating apps and i think i
don't think my profile is even removed
i don't haven't had the apps in years
and um i remember i
i sent uh somebody sent me a screenshot
in my instagram dms and was like
is this you on tinder and so i sent it
to my boyfriend at the time and i was
just like
i was like this i'm not on tinder if
anyone says i want tinder i was like i'm
not it's it's just
my profile's on there i don't know why
it's on there it must be from when i was
like
17 or 18 or whatever um yeah i don't
know how to take it down
apparently it's still on there you can't
they they make it almost impossible to
take it down
right so you have to basically download
the app log in and then just say hide my
profile
because deleting the file is near
impossible
what would you say some of the biggest
issues with these dating apps are then
and that you're trying to
trying to solve uh
fake people 30 of the guys that asked me
out are married
that happens on twitter as well by the
way on social media it's quite
unbelievable
oh yes and only 10 of them say i'm
ethically not monogamous i go great
that is wonderful i'm so happy that
you've got that figured out
i am ethically not monogamous what does
that mean
polyamorous it means all right
polyamorous okay ethically not
monogamous okay i've not had it put that
way
yes so so those are the key pieces is
that you really need
to have transparency and what do you
really want
you need to be honest with yourself what
do you really want right
and once you put that in there then the
a then the ai can help
but how we're getting it out there in
the first place is we're having this
conversation about me too
right you either have consent or you
don't period
right so you are not gonna win a sexual
harassment
defense if you don't have consent
because you've got all the data proving
it from the app essentially
right so your only defense is going to
be affirmative consent because right now
it's he said she said
and and here's the problem because i'm
not letting women off the hook i'm not
saying men are all
bad and i'm not saying oh i know plenty
of awful women that have accused men of
terrible things um i will just
i will just go back to me in my twenties
and i am not a horrible person
okay but i can totally see
how some women go over the edge so in my
20s
i would go to a club i would meet a guy
i had pretty much planned our wedding
within 15 minutes
no down damn girl
come on do you know how common this is
no i'm not like that we literally future
pace because we're not gonna actually
date somebody or sleep with somebody
that we wouldn't marry
right so okay go on keep going oh i
pretty much
planned the wedding where we're gonna
live how many kids we're gonna have
you know the pets the whole the whole
bit
or i say yes and go home with them and
have sex with them
then it you know it'll last a week
two weeks three weeks whatever and then
and then uh it fizzles out or whatever
and then i cry for a week and then
wash rinse repeat again uh
but but some women uh
the next when when it does fizzle out or
the next day
would be like oh well i would never
actually just have sex with someone just
to have sex with someone because it's
cognitive dissonance they would never do
that they
they were going to marry this person
that's why they had sex with them so if
they're not going to marry them then it
must have been right
you would not believe how many times
terrible
that's terrible so
it's it's a problem so wait are you
saying are you saying these women
because
they're i they're what they sort of
planned in their head for the future
didn't happen
they didn't consent to having sex
without the future that without getting
married basically
correct so that's nuts correct
so right so it protects men
from that and it protects women
from you know because she can just be
like i
do not consent right and
you know hopefully we can get this
spread out enough where
so the other thing is like in texas it
is a
third class misdemeanor and a 500 fine
to send an unsolicited dick pic
i'm waiting for this to get everywhere i
love that we could get that in the uk
that's all you see my dms are terrible
oh
right i only saved three
out of you saved why did you save it
because they were really good oh i was
like
oh uh oh yeah
okay that yeah i saved it i say
in a private locker they're not very
public but yeah three out of thousands
past muster for that was worth sending
so the other piece is you know if you
want to send somebody
a an explicit photo you need consent
right you should at least they sent it
through the app
they after they have consent they could
uh i say or or they have consent and
then they can send it however they want
it
but then you need to be able to revoke
consent when it's like you know what i'm
no longer interested in you revoke boom
very interesting i'm really interested
to see how this plays out and how it
works
um just because of how much sort of okay
dialogue
it sort of requires i find that really
fascinating to see how that's going to
play out do you see what i mean when i
say dialogue
you mean like role-playing like like no
no
yes like how direct you have to be about
what you want what they want
i don't know everything it's in the you
put that in the
here's the thing women oh you don't
speak
no talking okay do you know how
how old i was when i first opened my
mouth and said
can you do this and then he did it
and then my mind blew i remember telling
me this
i was 50
50. okay so women don't say anything
while naked and asked for what i wanted
like and that's common
we would literally we hit 50 and then we
just we're like what the [ __ ] why not
like right the ability to speak and ask
for what we want is great
so anyway that makes up for that
yeah it's all on the app okay so you
basically put in
so if you look at adult friend finder
it's the most honest app
right but i don't know it what is it
it's is it what it says it is it's a
naughty
swingers hookup naked
you know but you can and you are
literally as a woman bombarded by a wall
of cockshots and that is
not how we choose right like
and if your smile shoots joy out of your
eyes
i want to see that first because you
know if you're
like a horrible human even if you have a
great dick
that's a no for me that's right so it's
not how we choose
so but it is honest because it does show
what you like and what you're interested
in and what you're looking for and
people
are ridiculously honest on that app and
i'm like what if you could have
mainstream people be just as honest
but it not be publicly disclosed so this
is why we use the ai
because the ai does the matching like i
don't know what you want
that's in your that's the other piece of
the blockchain that's in your id
right when it goes to do the matching
it's matching you
but it's only looking at you you are
giving it permission to look
like i can't just log in and see you
know
your sexual preferences that's that's
not how it works
right but when it's matching you
together and when you're doing the
consent what it'll show you is it'll
highlight any mismatches
right okay it keeps that organic
anticipation
kind of you know surprise because it's
only going to call out like
and i'll just give you an example so um
this guy had been pursuing me for a year
and i finally i finally said yes to
coffee and then we went to dinner or
whatever
and then you know like three months into
it
find out we're we're not really
compatible
he was pretty good about one thing like
you can't choke me
like i was hung for witchcraft in a
previous life you touch my neck i'm
gonna kick your ass i can hold my own
damn breath i get the idea of being
choked
don't like it don't do it
he's like he could live with that but he
wanted me to call him daddy
i can't do that i have a child i'm just
not i'm not that's
i ca it i dry up
every time he wants me to call him daddy
i'm like i no
i can't so i can't date him right and
that would be on
basically that preference would be on
the app so you wouldn't have even needed
to be in that situation you're saying
right because he never would have
actually been ex i would have never seen
him because he would never have been
populated in the app
because there is this there is a a
critical mismatch
that i i mean i have it i'm not calling
you daddy
it it never gonna happen ever
right i do find that really weird if i'm
honest that is a hard no
what did you say i do find that really
weird and with you i find that really
really weird
it's i i can't i just can't right and
and he doesn't have kids so he doesn't
get it but everybody that i've talked to
who has kids they're like oh
ooh no i was like right i can't
and i get it but i i can't
that's my personal thing and here's the
other thing yeah
no judgment right everybody has their
own kinks their own quirks like i said
there's a lid for every pot
i'm not actually making any judgments no
children no animals no relatives
there you go i say that's pretty damn
liberal right no i think yeah i i think
i think it's really interesting and like
i said i'm just really excited to see
how it takes how it takes off and then
also
because this is obviously using the
ethereum blockchain
how do you think people outside of the
space will fare
in terms of getting involved in this do
you think they might feel oh no that's
blockchain technology i i don't
understand
yeah that's so that was the big thing is
people like oh i don't get blockchain so
i'm not gonna do it i'm like right
you're not gonna know it do you know how
your email works
you use your email every day
all the time do you know how email works
no
it's all about the ux right so we hide
the mechanics and they only see
the user interface and that's super easy
and very familiar which is how we're
driving blockchain adoption
into the mainstream because it's a
dating app everybody knows what a dating
app is
it's easy this is such an interesting
topic um i've been reading through the
comments as we've been talking and i'm
just finding the responses really
really interesting one person says
that's terrifying to me
um somebody else says i miss the old
days where you would go up to a woman
and compliment her now everything is
digital very sad
i do agree i i i'm very old school and
very traditional
i miss the old days where men would come
up and compliment me
you miss it too i i miss
like okay i walk through the world and
if i see a woman who's got
a nice outfit on i like her shoes i like
her hair whatever i
compliment her why because nobody is
complimenting anybody anymore
so i do it all the time every
opportunity i possibly can
because i just know it's not happening
yeah just on that point
a few years ago before covered when we
were allowed outside
um i i saw a girl i live i was living in
london at the time and i saw a girl
on the train and she had the most
unbelievable shoes
they were stunning and i had to tell her
so i told her i said
i was like wow your shoes are
unbelievable and
she just thought like i was going to
like stab her or something she just gave
me a terrible look
yeah it's really interesting it's really
interesting how you know complimenting
someone
is almost the most
uh terrifying thing for people because
it's so uncommon
and then i also think just you mentioned
the metoo campaign i also think off the
back of that a lot of men are sort of
afraid
so something that something that was
really interesting so
the actor henry cavill so if anyone's if
anyone doesn't know who he is he's the
guy who plays superman
um anyway he he's gorgeous and i and
he's single i believe
um and he basically made a comment
during the metoo campaign and he said
he's afraid to approach a woman now
because he feels like he's traditional
and a woman should be
um she should be pursued and he feels
like he'll be told off for sexual
harassment
anyway the metoo movement was very angry
about that
but i think he has a point i i think he
absolutely has a point
he absolutely has a point literally this
is what the app solves
okay okay if you are a woman
and you are interested in a man you
basically give
that man the green light to compliment
you
ask you out because you're you're
basically acknowledging yes i'm
interested in being pursued
i see i see it's oh gosh
it's an interesting one that that sort
of push and pull between
a natural romance versus giving the
green light
but it's necessary because i feel like
on both ends men are at risk women are
at risk so it's kind of come down to
that
right it's terrible it's the fact that
it's this
it's very dystopian right yes it is
dystopian
and i'm sorry i didn't create
this culture i'm just trying to solve it
and make it a little bit more seamless
so that great people can literally just
you know click i like this person and
it's green lighter note and if it's a
green light then they can
they can pursue and it does they don't
have to pursue on the app if they know
the person
yeah there you go i think you hit the
nail on the head though is it because
the comments are really interesting and
i think
i think that the response in general is
going to be really interesting people
will feel
that this is dystopian but it's kind of
something which has come off the back of
a culture that's
already grown yeah coming to
come into light i'm not sure the best
word to use
for that for that one but something i
really wanted to tell you actually um
so when we did our first interview i
think it was over a year ago
when we were doing it so we were in a
much more formal setting so i was in a
newsroom
um i had it was it was also quite late
in my time so it was just me and then i
had a couple of guys
in the um control room and starting to
take anyway they heard everything
and you were far more but you you were
far more uh
explicit then which is good which is
good i'm just honestly i'm pleased you
weren't now because i don't think i
would have handled it
back then you were so explicit and i
just i just remember
being in such a formal setting and just
sort of thinking
you were asking me you were like do you
know
you you're sort of like um oh sometimes
i feel i feel this way do you know what
i mean leia and i was like
i'm at work stop it
honestly well it was really interesting
it's
it's very funny so um you know every
time i do a pitch competition or every
time i
you know i i talk and you know talk
about what i'm
what i'm working on and talk about the
app they're like are you a stand-up
comic
and i was like okay so i need to do a
pitch competition after dark at a comedy
club
with booze because i think then people
would actually
get it better i really agree with you
yeah yeah i think so i think because
like
it is dystopian yeah um someone just
goes this is insanity what's wrong with
women
um this is just a reaction
okay no no no no no no no wait no
no no no no i am equal opportunity
let me explain to you a date i had
where i said we can meet in public
for coffee and he's like
okay well meet me at the gas station
because where we're going is a little
hard to find so
i meet him at the gas station i'm not
sure what the [ __ ] is going on
and he should we go around i follow him
in the car
to a parking lot and i think we're gonna
go to a coffee shop now i think he's
just leaving his
car there he gets in my car and i i
start to drive off he goes where are you
going and i'm like
where are we going he goes we're here
i'm like what do you mean we're here i
said public coffee he goes this is
public
it's the post office parking lot and i
go
i said we could meet in public for
coffee he goes oh no i don't do that
and i have
a taser and mace in my side door
and i demanded that he get out of my car
and then all i could think of was i'm
going to be murdered
my app wasn't out so i couldn't check
this guy out ahead of time
and i'm going to be murdered and and
it's going to be just
like the worst they're gonna they're
gonna just crucify me for letting a guy
in my car yeah i would never why'd you
let a guy in your car well
i wasn't thinking i thought we were
going to a coffee shop around you know
what i mean like i
yeah this is what happens when women are
unwillingly celibate for too long we
make poor choices and this is the other
thing that the app is going to solve
because it will actually backstop these
choices and
let it and notify us if we're about to
make a poor choice are you sure you
really want to make this poor choice
i think it's really interesting i'm just
so excited to see how people react to it
and how it takes off
um it's going to be really really
interesting so do we have a timeline
when can we expect it being released i
know you said you had some trademark
and copyright issues we have a little
trademark infringement going on that
we're trying to solve so
uh hopefully that will be done soon we
will get the rebrand done
and within a couple of months the
consent app will be out so that's the
plan
and then once we hit density about
five to ten thousand users per city
then we'll open up the dating app in
that city
because we want to make sure we have
real users so that's another thing and i
don't know if you're on clubhouse
but i am we should do something on
clubhouse actually
oh oh girlfriend oh yeah we
so should so i live on clubhouse but the
way that they did the onboarding it's
exactly the way that i had
uh have in our plan for how we do the
onboarding which is somebody has to
vouch
for you to get in yeah i think honestly
i think that's the smartest idea
especially when it comes to dating apps
um i think this was the natural
evolution of dating apps
everybody hates them but there's clearly
a need for them
um yes they are shallow they don't
it's just the nature they don't have to
be they don't have to be to be
but this is a natural evolution right
and that's okay and it's it's forever
it's for some and it's not for some and
that's also fine so
people don't have to be upset and
offended by it you know if if it works
for some then it works for some if it
doesn't then it doesn't
um but what i will say is no getting in
cars with strangers
none of that i already got my butt
kicked about that one
um probably about 400 comments
and they were like you know after the
initial shock of
okay so you're still alive now let me
kick your ass
so yeah i did literally everything i've
told everybody not to do but
you know again again
if i can make mistakes like that and i
actually know what i'm doing uh
imagine other women who aren't quite so
educated in all of this
and again unwilling celibacy
makes us make poor choices so i'd rather
that the choices be better right so
this is my whole thing when you've been
unwillingly celibate for a long time
you get a little desperate that's the
two o'clock in the morning thing and you
make four choices
at least with the app the choices that
are going to be available to you
are quality choices who are not going to
stalk you not going to murder you not
going to be
you know not going to be a problem
aren't going to give you anything safe
generally safe right so so i have a lot
of guy friends who are
they're cute they got nice bodies
according to their ex-girlfriends
they've got great dick and they know how
to use it
like they got they've got their vouched
for
um they are not long-term material
right they're just for one reason or
another like
they're already on the bachelor thing
never getting married never having kids
whatever i'm like you say that now
until you meet your woman and then
you'll do the george clooney thing and
get married and have twins
so you know it but they're not
gonna be like the long-term person that
suggested but if you lower that down to
a five
i have an entire stable of guys that are
absolutely perfect for a five they're
lovely they're kind
they're funny you know if you just need
to cuddle and cry
like and then and have sex and then
cuddle and cry
like there i go i got several who can
handle that too
so that's i love it that's the whole
point it's like what exactly do you need
what do you want what do you need
because sometimes we really just need a
naked cuddle
i love that you've built something based
off of what
from your own experience and from your
own kind of needs and your own what you
feel
is missing in the market and it's also
from a focus
group of a thousand women so it's not
just my needs it is
built that's where the initial idea i
mean yeah but it is built for women
by women the team is almost all women
uh four women by women about women so
the entire ai and the matching
everything is all based on how women
think
what they need you know all that it's
all based on women
it's not and none of the other apps are
like that
at all they're all built like they're
just built from
by men the oh my god this guy came out
with a consent app right after mine
and i was like are you [ __ ] me like
is it is it out and available what's it
called it's like the consent app or
something like that
it's terrible it's a single kind of it's
a single point of consent it's just it's
like it doesn't under
the whole they keep trying to steal the
features like i've had
i've had eight of my key features like
co-opted by other dating apps
that's nice and i'm like yeah but they
don't get it
like they go oh tinder we'll put in a
panic button i'm like
yeah it goes deeper than that because
i'm not going to be able to reach
my phone and press a freaking panic
button
yeah no i get it i feel like
i guess to summarize it's kind of it's
consent on the blockchain
it's a i so you can find somebody that
you want either if it's for a night or
for a long term
um and what would you say the third
point is
uh it teaches people to have transparent
communication about what they really
want so it's actually
we use a lot of nlp neuro-linguistic
programming to get people
uh to shift their mindset and really
overcome some of their their issues
um so there's a lot of personal
development worked into it because in
order to actually have a successful
long-term relationship
you need to do the work where can people
find you follow you and maybe ask to
take you on a date
oh lolly.io for
the app and at adrian a-d-r-y-e-n-n
pretty much everywhere perfect
do you have any last thoughts any last
whatevers you want to share i'm single
my age range preference is somewhere
between
35 and 70. i've got that big range
because my former husband is
in his late 60s and my
first boyfriend after being single for
nine years celibate for seven was 28 and
i was almost 50.
he's now 30. but i think 35 is probably
a better age
i'm not having any more children i'm a
little bit of a size queen
uh i like smart sapiosexual if they're
not smart it's not gonna happen
so scout for me pretty please there you
go agent thank you so much i really
appreciate you being so honest and open
with us
and giving us the full lowdown of what
is going on thank you so much for coming
on
thank you for having me again absolutely
and thanks everyone for watching i will
see you all next week
on thursday at 12 p.m est bye
[Music]
[Applause]